je vous dirais que la réponse à cette
question c'est avant tout le silence
le silence du cosmos qui est écouté et
interrogé par les instruments
astronomiques
les radiotélescopes surtout explorée par
des sondes spatiales
mais l'espace est resté muet jusqu'à
présent mais là au delà de ce silence on
a quand même pu faire des observations
et que nous distille ses observations
récemment la recherche spatiale a cédé
grands progrès et en particulier les
centres pioneer et volodia nous ont
donné des résultats étonnants et chose
curieuse ce ne sont pas les planètes en
principe propices à la vie c'est-à-dire
mars et vénus qui a révélé des
nouveautés main ce sont des satellites
des grandes planètes froide glacée à moi
sans moins 200 degrés jupiter réception
il ya deux satellites europa et titan
qui se sont révélés comme étant des
mondes où la vie peut-être pourrait
émerger au delà du système solaire est
ce qu'on peut penser imaginer qu'il y
ait de la vie c'est tentant évidemment
surtout quand on sait que dans notre
seule galaxie existe des millions des
galaxies se trouve plus de 100 milliards
des toiles que notre soleil autour
desquels gravitent peut être unitaire
comme la nôtre c'est la vie de toute une
école de scientifiques de tous les pays
qui dit que là où existe la matière
première pour former des êtres vivants
ils se forment automatiquement et donc
il y aurait actuellement notre galaxie
à peu près au plus 500 millions de
société intelligente qui cohabiterait
c'est une école qui est seule hypothèse
une autre école qui a les mêmes
arguments le même nombre aussi peu
d'arguments dit au contraire que la vie
n'apparaît que très rarement et
l'intelligence encore moins et donc nous
les humains nous serions les seuls êtres
évoluer dans notre galaxie nous soyons
seul actuellement dans l'univers connu
lors ce programme est tout à fait
scientifique est ce qu'il laisse place
quand même pour le rêve
je dirais très peu parce que nous sommes
dans un observatoire astronomique et
nous aimerions avant tout faire une mise
au point réel objective mais ce papa il
suffit de voir les étoiles des
nébuleuses pour qu'automatiquement rêve